as podcast has bad words hmm hello
simpletons what's up y'all today is uh
well it's a weird day yeah
we've we've had a lot going on this past
week it last week has felt like an
eternity and and so by the way this is
minimalist podcasts we discuss what it
means to live a meaningful life with
less and in these times especially today
we're gonna talk about pandemic
preparation I'm Joshua fields Milburn
I'm Ryan Nicodemus and together we are
the minimalist and we got our NVP here
with us yes indeed and and so TK Coleman
is here our returning champion he is
he's been on this podcast I think more
than anyone else at this point yeah mmmm
and so TK was in town because we were
working on a film project with Netflix
and we had about 30 people coming into
town in total from Crewe and and other
people we were interviewing and because
of what's going on with the coronavirus
we had to postpone the entire thing and
this is the second thing we actually
postponed this week we had to postpone
our les Coast tour which TK was gonna
join us on in Sacramento we're gonna
postpone that we're looking at some
dates in September or November but
that's simply an inconvenience so we're
gonna talk about the coronavirus today a
little bit but I wanted to talk more
broadly about preparation yeah not not
in the sense of prepping like Preppers
or yeah but preparing right right and
and so I'm gonna argue today that
minimalists are actually more prepared
to deal with catastrophe more prepared
to deal with pandemics than the average
person yeah and certainly more so than a
lot of so-called Preppers and so these
are some somber times but I do want to
handle a lot of it with jokes and so
we're going to be we're gonna be as
upbeat as possible today this is the
first time I've been in a room with more
than Beck's and nearly a week at this
point you must be going crazy yeah I
have been self-quarantine but I've been
self quarantine for 38 years
and as an extreme introvert and now here
we are today we've got some questions
for Josh people are a germ right exactly
exactly they love people but from a
distance so so TK we're gonna I think we
should probably dive into some of these
questions but before we do that I just
wanted to we have this essay on our
website I'll try to read a little bit of
it because I had to be a good jump off
point for us to talk about the
coronavirus today but then later this
week we're gonna do an episode just
about the coronavirus and you should we
call that a maximal episode we usually
put it on patreon only for our patrons
by the way thank you for our patrons
I know it's just two dollars but that's
what supports this podcast keeps it 100
percent advertisement free we couldn't
do without our patrons we quite
literally couldn't do it in a space we
couldn't pay Shawn and Jordan and Jess
and ourselves without because we don't
believe in doing ads and so we're not
going to do advertisements and so you
all help keep this afloat but as a
public service announcement later this
week in the normal feed we're gonna put
the coronavirus patreon episode on
Friday in the normal minimal podcast
feed so everyone will have access to it
the patrons will have access to it a day
early but we want to get this out as
sort of a a public service announcement
before we dive into our questions let me
just read this this is from our website
you can find this over at the
minimalists comm slash coronavirus and
it's an essay called let's talk about
the corona virus and this came out on
March 12 2020 so things are changing
literally by the day we're recording
this on the 14th I think it comes out on
we're getting here on a Saturday because
there are fewer people here yeah on a on
a Saturday and it makes sense for us to
do it here but the essay goes a little
something like this I prefer to live my
life by the maxim most emergencies
aren't adhering to this sentiment I
avoid overreacting or panicking of
course every so often there are real
emergencies even then it's better to
prepare than to panic we never look in
the rearview and wish we would have
panicked more as of today we are unsure
whether the novel coronavirus and its
resulting disease co vid 19 is a
widespread emergency or an overreaction
to be clear it's already an emergency
for some many people have died many more
ill and many healthcare providers are
risking their lives to keep people alive
and there's a significant likelihood it
will get worse in the coming months
while you and I don't know whether we'll
be directly affected will certainly be
indirectly affected the stock market is
tanking factories are ceasing production
stores are running out of inventory
schools and museums are closing and many
public gatherings are being cancelled or
postponed to date South by Southwest
Coachella the Houston Rodeo the Tucson
Festival of Books and hundreds of other
events conferences and rallies have
shuttered under the threat of infection
even the NBA has suspended a season and
that in that same consideration for
safety the minimalists have decided to
postpone our Lesko store until this fall
to protect our audience details will be
published on our tour page as soon as
they are available
we believe this is the appropriate call
given the best information we have about
the virus so far all of this can be
extremely aggravating these setbacks are
mere and conveniences in the grand
scheme of things the actual problem
might be far more serious than shifting
around our calendars it might mean
changing how we live for the foreseeable
future as we learn more about the
severity of this pandemic
I'm personally being vigilant by asking
our entire team to work from home except
for today while we're in the studio but
usually we come in here three four or
five days a week I'm usually in here six
days a week and I've been working from
home they've been working from home
asking people to work from home is one
of the more responsible things to do
because well as I get to in a moment
it's not just about you and whether or
not you can get sick and withstand it
you can pass on a virus that could
literally kill people and so even us
coming in here today was quite the risk
we're not hugging for the first time
ever which by the way is the next bullet
point here shunning hunt handshakes and
gasp even hugs
it was so hard CK came in here to then
my first thing I would do is I haven't
seen CK in months I wanted to give him
right but I'm I'm doing it not just for
my own safety but for everyone else is
canceling non-essential travel that's
something that's important ll was
supposed to travel here this week we
were supposed to have a spring break
together that's done we're still trying
to figure out the logistics backs is
supposed to get on plane tomorrow I'm
incredibly worried about that in fact I
was talking to some doctors this
yesterday actually which seems like a a
week ago now and after talking to five
doctors none of them could give me a
test yeah how to get a test it's so
scary and I even heard like the Utah
Jazz when when they were first and we
found out they were infected
they took fifty-eight of the tests that
Oklahoma had only 75 tests that day and
they took 58 of them to test people I
think by the way I'm a huge Utah Jazz -
I think what they did is incredibly
irresponsible what a dick move yeah take
58 tests of the 75 for people who did
not who were not symptomatic my way and
I understand why they did it but it
underlines a problem that we have and
how I mean there are countries there are
third ball countries who are handling
this better than the United States of
America and this is not a political
partisan statement but it is a political
statement in terms of the affairs of the
city or the affairs of the country and
we have not been prepared for this and
so there are countries in West Africa
that we think of as third-world
countries who are so far beyond what we
are doing a sin of Gaul is a great
example of this they're inventing not
just tests but new ways to test people
within 10 minutes possibly on-site so
you can do these drive throughs give
them results within 10 minutes and we
can't even figure out in fact the FDA
and the CDC it almost seems like they
conspired at this point new to make the
pandemic worse and they didn't it was
bureaucratic nonsense now DK is our
resident free market libertarian here
and so we're gonna dive into free market
advocate I would I would lighten up on
the the libertarian there we go yeah
yeah it's uh well I mean this just goes
to show like this is where from me
something like libertarianism it falls
apart a little bit
because in this situation it's only rich
NBA players can get the tests and what
is something wrong with that and and
even even then like I was talking to
doctrine who is in sports medicine and
they they got it because they didn't
have access to the test either they had
to they had people from the hospital who
were able to get the test for them so
you're right it is the it is this moment
where you have to not only have the
money but have the access have the
connection yeah have that and I have
great here's the here's the problem I
have is I have really good connections
so the average person listen to this
doesn't have the connections that I have
yeah there's no way you're gonna get a
test unless you get really really really
lucky yeah that's a great point let's
talk about and I will get back into this
hopefully or maybe we'll save it for the
maximal but TK let's talk a bit about
the free market here and and I mean
jokingly I I text you the other day
ribbing you saying your anymore your
free market is failing us and we're
actually gonna next week we're gonna do
an episode with TK about the economy so
so we'll be talking a lot more about the
free market and and and what to do in
these uncertain times of economic
uncertainty and and so let's talk about
the free market now and and how how is
it helping how is it failing us in a way
yeah well freedom is a funny thing man
you know in America especially we use
very romanticized terminology to talk
about things like Liberty but the
reality is freedom is harder and harsher
than many of the alternatives in a whole
lot of ways you know like you you this
is why it's so difficult to fight for
and it's so difficult to hold on to when
we have it you know the way I see the
story of human history is that you've
got you've got two conflicting paradigms
the way of creativity and the way of
coercion the way of creativity is the
way of freedom it's figuring out how to
solve our problems without resorting to
violence
yeah the way of coercion is the way of
force it's about solving problems
through suppression through oppression
through enslavement and so forth and the
thing about the way of coercion is it
offers us very easy answers we can solve
a lot of problems real quickly if we can
just enslave you oppress you suppress
you whip you beat you and make you do
what we want you to do but that
generates long term consequences that
are terrible for everyone the way of
creativity the way of freedom it offers
us more possibilities but also more
responsibilities and that's agonizing so
to use an everyday example if I move
away from home because I don't like
playing by my parent's rules and I have
my own place well now you can't tell me
what time to go to bed you can't give me
curfew you can't tell me how allowed to
play my music I am free you can eat ice
cream for breakfast for breakfast right
I am free right but with that freedom
now comes like a million and one things
that I have to manage that I didn't have
before and there are a million in one
ways that my life can go wrong so
whenever we have a crisis they put a
little pressure on us they say do we
really value this thing that we call
freedom because there are a lot of
problems right now
and we can get some quick easy answers
that calm everyone down if we just
resort to the lazy way the way of
coercion the way of leaning on the power
of legislative force to make everyone do
the things that we want to do but that's
not always the right way because
unintended negative consequences are a
reality and economists point this out
all the time it's not an emotionally
satisfying answer but it's a reality and
so my challenge is as we think about
things like this that we do the hard
work of advocating for creative
solutions right and moments like this
are sort of an example of kind of like
the complexities and the challenges that
come along with with freedom because you
sent me an article for instance I think
there was some guy that was just yeah
we're gonna talk about that next week
I'll pause here yeah I'm enraged by this
guy so tune in next week when we're
talking about the account or yeah the
economy because this to me is an example
of the free market failing the free
market then succeeding but still
enraging me in ways that I do believe
some authority I I'm feeling although
I'm feeling
authoritarian ISM from the community is
an example but or is is the the path but
we'll get to that let's but I just do
want to say this though because being in
this position of like advocating for the
power of freedom and the beauty of
freedom III get presented with scenarios
all the time where people are like hey
here's a bad guy that did a bad thing
right now what do you got to think about
freedom and I like to set the context
for those discussions by just pointing
out I cannot be free to love you unless
I'm free to hurt you I cannot be free to
serve you unless I'm free to exploit you
right I cannot be free to be a blessing
in your life unless I'm free to be a
curse so let's before we have any
debates about freedom let's start with
the fundamental acknowledgment that the
very nature of freedom provides us with
the power to do very harmful and hurtful
things because freedom isn't just the
right to do whatever we want it's the
responsibility to do a whole bunch of
other things that are necessary to
sustain those rights and that is
literally the hardest thing for human
beings to do it is not easy for us to be
free no it's not what you're saying is
is what this freedom comes a great
responsibility and it's up to us to be
responsible now
there's the you talked about how some
people are like oh this one guy did this
one bad thing and but here's the thing
is there's always an exception to the
rule there's always a point where you
know you've got something happy like
freedom is great ninety nine percent of
the time and then there's just one
percent of the time where you know [ __ ]
hits the fan where whether it's the
coronavirus or whether it's
environmentally or whatever it is yes
like we are not responsible enough as a
society but I mean I think we're really
what we're saying here though is like
there is a balance there's a balance
between 100% free market and then a
little bit of regulation I hate
regulations I think regulations are they
suck but I do think that unfortunately
because of humans and our tendency to
not be responsible we do that's why we
have police on the street is because
people you know you've got to have
someone enforcing some type of laws cuz
otherwise yes you have people who are
eating ice cream for breakfast every
single day which you know actually
people can't do that right now and
they've got diabetes right what are you
talking about a self-regulation first
and then
there are times where necessary
regulations might make sense on a on a
community local or national level or
even worldwide level right yeah when you
are preventing harm spreading throughout
the community and to other people like
that is where I think regulation has to
be and you know what I mean
unfortunately there's just not there's
no easy answer this isn't like a binary
rang it's not no freedom or freedom it
is it's a balance and you know if I de
pick between a binary choice I would
definitely choose freedom yeah well on
the maximum episode I want to talk to
you both about I think that that we even
call it anarchism or libertarianism or
whatever we're gonna call it whatever
the term voluntary ISM okay there we go
I like that we can call it whatever true
free market I think the only time it
existed and worked was pre civilization
and we're gonna talk about that because
I think it actually worked really well I
think there were socialist libertarians
in pre civilization and I think dr.
Christopher Ryan wrote civilized to
death and I think it's the best case for
both socialism and libertarianism
simultaneously and I want to talk to you
both about that before we getting these
questions you brought up something that
I just want to want to put out there so
on social media we just posted this
today or last night before we're
recording this and it goes something
like this
as a picture on our Instagram account
and it says this with all the important
social distance distancing that's going
on right now the minimalists are going
to practice some social media distancing
for a while too because we want to avoid
adding to the noise during these
reactive times we'll still post new
podcast episodes and necessary updates
but that's it for a while we're also
gonna record a podcast episode about the
pandemics I talked about that and then
the itis end of this post with we are
going to see the best and the worst
parts of our communities in the coming
weeks yeah do your best to be the best
part and then safe out there man we we
cannot reiterate that enough it's like
anyone listening to this who is
experiencing this panic and this
craziness in their community the best
thing you can do is be a good citizen
like that is you look out for yourself
of course and be
safe but when you can't also look out
for other people and sometimes the best
way to do that is to - so I there's a
line in this post I'll just go back to
it real quick it says let's see a
statement here respond to the pandemic
oh it's not here but anyway sometimes oh
yeah it's it's in the the essay that I
wrote back to the coronavirus essay and
it basically just said that look I know
our individual our individualistic
society is not very good at slowing down
or self regulating but we must at least
for a while it's no longer just about
you and me we must consider everyone
else which seems like a paradox when we
talk about social distancing but right
now one of the best things we can do is
love people from afar because even if
you are worried about the virus yourself
you can transmit it to others if you're
not careful and spreading the disease
will lead to greater human suffering
yeah that's why even making this
decision to come in here today with
relatively few people it was a serious
decision where we've been self
quarantine and I've been doing a bunch
of things we'll talk about what we're
doing to to sort of self quarantine and
to help out we'll talk about that on the
maximal episode but I just want to get
into some of these questions for the
sake of time and then we'll talk much
more about the corona virus on the
maximal which will have access to this
week it's interesting man we've been
self regulating for the last you know a
decade right a little bit more than that
as minimalist
yeah and it's crazy I was TK I was
telling Josh and the guys here earlier
how when I was calling all of the people
we were supposed to interview for the
documentary that we had to cancel and I
literally called like 18 people
yesterday just apologizing and also
saying thank you but so many of them
were like man I'm so glad that I have
chosen a simple life because they have
they're not panicking they're not a lot
of them have become debt free so they're
you know if they don't work for a little
bit that's okay I mean they still got to
make money pay their bills eventually
but having big debt payments is is
something that I think a lot of people
are panicking over right now I mean 40%
of Americans can't afford a $400
emergency so imagine like being in that
situation and now
you've got the coronavirus you have to
choose between paying your bills or
risking yourself getting the coronavirus
it's uh yeah it's it's we've been self
regulating for the past decade and I
can't I cannot I have never been more
appreciative of the lifestyle that that
I've chosen yeah and to your earlier
point about how minimalist can be you
know better prepared for these kinds of
scenarios you know consumerism is a
compromise on your liquidity and your
liquidity is is is your biggest it is
your biggest advantage in moments like
this right if you're just spinning your
money on a bunch of immediate
gratification on a bunch of cool
glamorous glitzy stuff what happens when
a crisis strikes and your need for water
your need for toilet paper increases
well you're not very liquid because you
spent your money on a bunch of trinket
ring kits right that aren't very useful
to you at a time of crisis so it always
pays off to be mindful even if it's not
obvious you know how that's gonna pay
off in the present mean a Rolex isn't
gonna fend off the coronavirus it's what
do you say that we're back so now we're
driving down Sunset Boulevard yesterday
and I see this ad for like a Ralph
Lauren and it's like a guy dressed in a
nice suit
a very attractive man wearing like this
flashy suit and in this time of like it
feels like we're in a zombie apocalypse
which our first question has to do with
that actually and and I see I see this
guy I realize how absurd like that we we
often treat that as if it matters the
the Ralph Lauren suit but it never
mattered and these times actually
illustrate that we talked about being
the best in your community not part of
the worse let me give you an
illustration of the worst real quick
this is a tweet now Shawn I'll send this
to you we'll put a link to this tweet
and the show knows but you know I went
to I went to Target this week literally
just to do my regular shopping right
yeah and it was on Thursday and so last
Thursday for you all listening to this
and and I took a snap to picture the
entire you know toilet paper paper towel
Isles gone got just obliterated right
well someone put this sign up at one of
these stores and it said dear shoppers
due to the recent outbreak of stupidity
and panic purchasing by Complete Idiot's
the nation is currently experiencing a
shortage of toilet paper and common
sense
expect supplies to be replenished once
these sheep minded morons have all
starved to death in their home
surrounded by toilet paper but without
anything I don't know you can make
toilet paper smoothies did this bit
where he was like why are people
hoarding twelve paper you you realize it
like you're pooping in the same room
that has a shower in it yeah like if you
run out of toilet paper you're going to
be okay yeah well a lot and I guess
we'll talk abouts in the economy episode
for next week but it's it's people
honestly a lot of it is people taking
any advantage is what it is yeah we're
definitely talk about that our first
question today is from Michelle in
Alabama
I've been abducted with some minimalist
lifestyle for a couple months and I'm
only 17
but before that I was really passionate
about watching zombie shows and movies
and all that jazz and I was wondering
how much survivability there's a
minimalist have a zombie apocalypse
story to happen so this is exactly the
zombie apocalypse right no but we are
talking about preparing for an
unexpected sort of circumstance here I
don't think TK you're gonna advocate for
you know the the TV show Preppers but
how are we already prepared in ways that
maybe we don't understand were prepared
by the way when she was asking this
question she says I've they're really
it's a zombie no no she said I'm so when
I thought she was gonna say cuz she's
like I've been into the minimalist
lifestyle for too much but I'm really
passionate about zombie movies do I have
to stop watching them that's where I
thought I just wanna praise that
question it might be the best of all
time well I'm lucky that I have really
good friends like Ryan and Sean who have
guns and and sean has lots of guns yeah
and so I think I'll be fine just because
yeah by proxy yeah yeah we're gonna hop
in my Toyota and go and proxy all Sean's
guns we know but let's talk about ways
we're prepared and wait we don't think
about that we're necessarily prepared
but how
has simple living intentionality being
more delivered with our lives prepared
us for something like this current
epidemic this current crisis this
current pandemic yeah well so in order
to live mindfully and and and adopt the
simple lifestyle you have to be very
good at not allowing your reactions to
life to be dictated by mainstream
thinking right you have to sort of
unplugged from groupthink and say I'm
gonna live cautiously I'm not gonna buy
something just because everyone else is
rushing to the [ __ ] this to the sale I'm
not gonna do the what is it Black
Thursday Black Friday buy fiber Monday
is something that they got some for
everyday now like winners Wednesday is
coming out I was planning the same thing
for my Netflix appearance in order to
live mindfully you have to learn how to
make a distinction between how you are
going to live and how everyone else is
living right so let's bring it back to
the zombie apocalypse because what I
love about zombie movies is there are
always two elements that you have to
respond to what is the actual crisis
that's producing the zombie problem
right there's usually some sort of virus
some sort of like poison that everyone's
eating that's changing them but the
second element would be the zombies
themselves the people that you know and
love that you've been living your life
with and now they're kind of like
becoming a direct to you right and I
think that's a perfect analogy for the
times that we live in because there
there's there are two crises we have to
respond to one is the actual outbreak
and what we're gonna do about that but
the second thing is the reactions that
other people are having what are we
gonna do about that what am I gonna do
about the fact that I don't feel the
need to buy all the water in the grocery
store right but I know that all of these
other guys over here are gonna buy it
all up and now there's a temptation to
let those people force my hand there's a
temptation for me to become something
that I'm not out of a reaction to other
people's panic even if I'm not panic I
have to kind of live like I'm panicked
because other people are and so one of
the things that these zombie movies
illustrate is that our
twofold we can't effectively deal with
the crisis unless we manage our reaction
to other people and that means you have
to sort of extricate yourself from being
from being too heavily influenced by
other people and one way that you can do
that is you can sort of control your
level of intake your information intake
don't be a victim of the 24-hour news
site one of the problems of today is
that we mistake medium for message all
of these new mediums have put a lot of
pressure on these news networks to
constantly have something to say even if
there's nothing to say if you got a
Twitter channel and it's been 2 hours
since you tweet it you better put
something out there because our
competitors are doing it right if you've
got an Instagram page you better post
every day because we're gonna lose to
our competitors and so we can become
seduced into thinking that there's
always something to listen to about the
coronavirus or something to panic about
something to panic about and that's when
you get caught up in that zombie
groupthink mindset and you have to
unplug from that and say you know what
no I'm not gonna watch this all day I'm
gonna stay informed but I'm also gonna
stay constructive and I'm gonna give
myself a few creative things to think
about I'm gonna give myself a few
family-oriented things to think about
I'm gonna deliberately ignore my phone
for an hour I'm gonna turn off my TV for
the next three hours anything I can't
deal with for the next three hours my
problems are bigger than the coronavirus
right and that's the same kind of
mindfulness that allows you to live
minimalistic ly in everyday life is that
making sense you know it makes perfect
sense man I'm glad you're bringing this
up because that it wait what I heard you
say was this self regulation this
mindfulness it helps us basically choose
how we want to react to these impulses
because I'll tell you I went to Mariah I
went to Trader Joe's just to get some
normal fruit and things that we were
gonna get and the shelves were empty and
there is this sense of panic that
started to take me over like I'm not
even joking like it was very much like
oh my god like I really really I relied
to talk myself down but because of the
last ten years of self regulating I was
able to be like Ryan look man like you
can still get groceries when they
restock like the supply chain isn't
totally interrupted but I had to like go
through this exercise of not just
wanting to go get a shopping cart and
just buy everything that I could at that
time and that's the opposite of being
intentional right what you're talking
right but I love the design be
apocalypse question
because what TK is really saying here is
it's turning us into zombie yeah yeah
our reaction the the people I mean the
the the posts I just shared on Twitter
is like the musci poll right we become
you know whatever metaphor you want to
use zombie sheeple idiots whatever it is
is we when we fall into that group think
the mob mentality the mob rule and in
fact it's one of the reasons that
populism is dangerous right because
populism on one side can produce
something really amazing like like
democracy and everyone gets a vote
populism can also produce mob mentality
mob rule and and if you aren't
coalescing with this tribe than you are
the enemy yeah it's like well it's also
like if one gazelle starts running all
the gazelles they all start running they
all start fleeing it is and that's what
we're doing that well panicking and
running yeah and we're not reacting to
our inform knowledge about the actual
situation we're reacting to other
people's reactions so there's a Twilight
Zone episode called The Munsters are due
on Maple Street that kind of depicts the
scenario where this alien spaceship
descends on the earth and that the guy
on the radio announces oh my gosh you
know like these aliens are here and
there's this one guy that has like this
emergency shelter and he goes to hide
out in there and all of his neighbors
try to get in and over the course of the
thirty minute episode you just see these
people become so ugly to each other
because in a time of crisis we panic and
who we truly are begins to emerge right
and and the moral of the story in the
end is that the greatest enemy it's not
some monster that descends from the sky
it's it's how ugly we can become when we
react to tragedy in a way that isn't
mindful and that loses sight of the
value of humans so Truman what blew my
mind at Trader Joe's is how because
Mariah and I live in Hollywood and this
is like the most convenient store of
like in downtown Hollywood all of the
influencers that are like live-streaming
and like through it's like they're
taking advantage it's like the media is
taking advantage of it right now like
I'm saying influences or quotes by the
way yeah yeah but it but it's just crazy
how I mean again it just shows people's
true colors because I could tell the
people the people recording themselves
in live streaming it was
half a dozen people it's like they
weren't doing it to add value to the
community they were like oh here's a
situation that I can take advantage of
and I can aggregate more eyeballs and I
can get more money for ad revenue and
that's exactly what the media's doing
right now and I saw I saw this same
thing happened when Chernobyl was the
show the show came out and people
started visiting Chernobyl and you see
like these Instagram models and like
bikinis but like hazmat masks inter
noble and and they're they're just
taking advantage of of this and by the
way they're they're putting themselves
in danger and I think that's the
important thing to think about if and I
want to talk when we talk to coronavirus
episode I do want to talk specific
things that we can do to protect
ourselves and one of those things has to
do I'm just gonna read my list that's
part of this essay but I've got a whole
other essay from someone else who's much
smarter than me that I want to go
through with you all but I already
talked about working from home
impossible if you can do that work from
home and if you employ people like Ryan
and I do encourage your staff to work
from home as well don't force them but
encourage them to work from home
canceling all non-essential travel
especially on airplanes I was talking to
dr. Tommy what about this and he was
saying that you're actually on if you
get on an airplane you are more in
danger than if you were to spend a if
you were being if Shawn had the
coronavirus but he had a mask on we'd be
safer here than if you get on an
airplane because you just don't know and
the percentage of people we're talking
upwards of it could be as high as 70
percent the estimates usually are 30 to
50 percent of people are gonna contract
this over the next 12 to 18 months
anyway getting rid of handshakes and
hugs right now those have to be it's not
polite you're not doing anyone a favor
if you're hugging them if you're shaking
their hand you are doing them and you a
disservice and you're especially doing
your grandparents and older folks people
who are over 80 the mortality rate on
this thing is 22% we're talking a death
sentence for one out of five elderly
people and and you can give that to
someone oh I see do you see that yeah
you see that get him out of here its
podcast is over shooting turns into a
zombie we can I can I say one thing but
III think it's interesting just to play
on words for a little bit how sim
the word sanitize and sanity are mmm you
know so with all the emphasis that word
he's gonna preach other black preachers
just make sure you arrive back up career
I was also saving that for the Netflix
got the five some new tricks but so we
speak a lot about things like keeping
our hands clean but I also think it's
important to keep our heads clean right
to gain toxicity out of our lives
because just because you acknowledge
danger doesn't mean that you need to
live in fear and and I think the only
way that you can really ground yourself
in a mindset that's gonna be helpful to
people is it's to play by a rule that
says for every five minutes I'm
listening to the news I'm feeding myself
ten minutes of something that's gonna
actually nourish my soul whether that's
me meditating whether that's me watching
some healthy programming whether that's
reading a novel that's inspiring me
because of one thing you can be sure no
matter what hard times we go through you
are not gonna be helpful to anybody if
you are trying to help them from a state
of lack if you are trying to help them
from a state of panic it's like when
we're on the airplane what do they tell
us you know like like you got to stay
calm or like when you're calling 9-1-1
all of your all of your emotions make
you want to be like but you can't help
anybody like that right you got to stay
calm even though tragedies around you
man say I live at 555 Fifth Street
this is what's going on and that's
counterintuitive but that's how you
actually help people during a time of
emergency so do your best to be
realistic and informed but also do your
best to stay mentally healthy and stay
positively focused so if you are ever
called on to come through for somebody
in an emergency you can do that from a
state of poise and confidence yes yeah I
mean there's such a balance between like
overreacting and living in fear and then
you know some people still think that
it's not real yeah and it's like I mean
there is a there's a medium balance
there and I think that's what you're
talking about is
that balance is gonna save your life
potentially here a couple of things from
from the essay we'll put a link to this
and shown us so you can read the entire
thing you definitely should read it and
it just because it talks about
coronavirus preparation we're gonna talk
a lot more on on the Maxima which you
all will have access to as well and then
we got a couple more questions we'll try
to get to all that we're running out of
time here avoiding public spaces and
crowds of people so those two things
specifically any anywhere where crowds
of people are gathering and when I say
crowds of people I'm talking even this
cuz is is borderline crowd of people I
didn't check with everyone here whether
or not they had symptoms and even then
you still could have the the virus and
and be asymptomatic right now
so reducing grocery shopping that once a
week I strongly recommend going as soon
as the grocery store opens by the way
that tends to be the time where fewest
people are there some of the grocery
store I tend to go to opens at 7 a.m.
and so that's at the time tomorrow backs
and I are going to go 7 a.m. I betcha
sighs as they open I bet you the Stila
line there might be and if there is I'm
going to leave and so because I haven't
oh yeah I have I have enough if there's
a line if there's a crowd of people you
just leave and it's okay to do that
we're not talking about forever we're
talk about changing our lives for a
temporary period of time right now this
is a pandemic eventually it will become
endemic like the flu and and you know
we're looking at the death rates there
somewhere six to ten times what the flu
is but it's not but we don't have a a
mortality rate of say the avian flu if
we had that it'd be totally different
the avian flu has a 60% mortality rate
that is true in the world sort of zombie
movie pandemic we'll talk more about
that on the maximal a couple more
questions here in fact let's skip skip
Grace's question in Missouri Oh before
we do that Michelle I do want to send
you something we have a free ebook on
our resources page I think it's gonna
help you out a lot you're asking about
this how do I live more intentionally
well this ebook is called the minimalist
rulebook it's 16 rules for living with
less and in there we talk about just in
case items versus just for win items we
talk about your things like the 30-day
minimalism game obviously which is less
applicable right now but we have the
wait for it rule which i think is really
really important right now pausing and
just being able to wait for a
or a month in some cases you don't need
most of the things you think you need
you probably don't need four cases of
toilet paper you don't need any toilet
paper in an emergency I've never needed
emergency toilet paper I don't know what
about that one time know when when yeah
when you're when you were with Beck's
and you were like going through your
stomach stuff that might actually be the
first Christmas long and somehow I lived
through it all right
lightning round this is where we answer
your text messages you can text us nine
thirty seven two oh two four six five
four those text messages go both to
Ryan's phone and my phone we have more
time since we're quarantined ourselves
in our houses yeah so you can text us we
will try to respond to as many people as
possible we'll answer some of our
favorites on the podcast as well this
one is from s Schmidt I'd love to hear
your thoughts and preparing to
quarantine for two to six weeks while
living a more minimalist life well I'm
gonna echo something that that TK said
by the way the lightning round story
answer questions with a short shareable
s 140 character response we put the text
of these minimal Maxim's and the show
notes so you can copy and share our
pithy answers on social media if you
like and now you can find all of our
minimal Maxim's in one place over at
minimal maximum comm decays already said
several pithy things I've seen Sean
writing down so we'll have those in the
show notes for you as well over at the
minimalists comm I want to be the
confessor such as for pretty tales I'd
love to hear your thoughts on preparing
for a quarantine so here's the thing I
would just say don't let others
expectations dictate your standards and
right now the expectations are oh I have
to hoard I have to have this I have to
to I have to grab this before someone
else too does why did you have to do
that a week ago two weeks ago do you
think that the entire systems
going to fail that much and if so if you
do believe that then you need to look at
precedent because Wuhan didn't run out
of running water
Wuhan still had electricity and if the
epicenter of the pandemic still had
running water and electricity and do you
think you need to hoard water and do you
think you have to have a generator for
the it's it's we are overreacting in
times based on other people's
expectations yeah yeah yeah yeah I mean
I would just I don't know if I'd
something pithing cuz I don't have time
to prepare for this now I know how our
guests feel when we spring it on them
but I would just say be clear on what is
just in case and what is just for when
like personally Mariah and I in general
always have about two weeks worth of
meat in the freezer because we order
from us wellness meats calm and totally
not an advertisement but they have like
great grass-fed grass-finished beef it's
not super it's actually cheaper than
like going to Whole Foods and Los
Angeles and we ordered 1520 pounds at a
time because that's what we have to do
to get a bulk order that comes out
deep-frozen it's really it's it's great
so we haven't our freezer We certainly
have you know a week or two worth of
toilet paper and you know any anything
that we have soap we usually order that
because you can get you know and when
you buy five you can get a little bit of
a discount and I know we're gonna go
through it so all these items that I'm
talking about these are all things that
are just for when it's not just in case
so yeah absolutely yeah like we're yeah
and there's a balance between buying
toilet paper one sheet at a time and
then going to Walmart and buying every
single roll of toilet paper that they
have so when you when you live mindfully
it helps you to determine the just four
case items versus the just four when
items I'll say coronavirus don't care
about your politics it's not a liberal
thing or a conservative thing it's a
human thing you know resist the
temptation to politicize everything yeah
and the second thing I would say is an
ideological virus is just as dangerous
as a biological virus avoid the
ideological virus that comes from
letting other people do your thinking
for you bad information can and will
kill you
you got the time you're being forced to
stay home anyway take the time to do
your own research and think for yourself
yeah we got a bunch more to talk about
today we're gonna do this on the maximal
episode if you want to support us is the
minimalists com a slash support here are
some of the things we're gonna talk
about on the maximal episode we're
talking about prepping we're gonna talk
about how bad is this actually going to
be based on the stats we're gonna look
at actual stats and instead of just
speculating we're gonna talk about self
quarantine extorting now versus later
and what are the what are the different
effects we're what's the endgame here
out of all of this like it is is there
is there an in-game and if so what is it
stay alive that's the endgame right but
in the meantime what would also do we
accomplished we're gonna talk about home
health care we're going to talk about
who is most affected old people but also
how young people are affected by this
and in other ways we're gonna talk about
the view from China we're gonna talk
about that no problem is so bad that
over-regulation can't make it worse PK's
gonna like that it's a great point the
efficient market hypothesis is the real
victim we're gonna talk about that we're
also gonna talk about masks and
respirators are they good are they bad
tune in this week to find out and we're
talking about zinc and how that might
help out with the corona virus or might
not we're gonna talk about how it may or
may not help a supplements can open
generally yeah we're gonna talk about
optimism in general and then it looks
like Ryan we've got some more questions
here we've got questions about how much
stuff should we have on hand when
catastrophe happens we're gonna talk
about what items should I have an
emergency kit is it better to have
health insurance for a medical emergency
medical emergency or simply save money
for such occurrences and we're gonna
talk about how to spend our time while
we are self quarantine if we're spending
more time at home how we spend that time
and how do we avoid spending our time in
unhealthy ways if we are self quarantine
because I think that is a danger as well
if you want to hear all that listen to
this week's maximal episode on the
minimalist private podcast you can find
that over at the minimalists com a slash
support we're also gonna as a public
service announcement we'll put that in
the main feed this for
as well but we really do appreciate your
support yeah if you our patreon
supporter it keeps his podcast a hundred
percent advertisement free Ryan well she
got for us this week before we take off
let's listen to some comments and tips
from our listeners hi this is Josie from
Austin Texas
Bryan talked about replacing his
t-shirts every week every year really
were faded and smelly from also wearing
them to work out when I have a t-shirt
that's looking worn I move it to my
workout clothes and toss or donate what
I've been wearing to exercise that keeps
my regular clothes in better shape and
they last longer hey Josh and Ryan
Alisha from Australia just ringing
because I I was listening to your
Pittsburgh podcast and there was a woman
there was asking question about what to
do with her blanket that an aunt had
given to her and it was covered with
like photos of her as like growing up
and as a child and she does not want to
keep it and I had a suggestion that she
could donate it to an animal shelter any
blankets or you know old sheets or
towels or bedding and stuff that people
want to get rid of in in their mincing
journey animal shelters are a great
option because obviously the animals not
going to care if there's a warm blanket
with the picture of your face on it um
they're just gonna be grateful that they
have something warm to snuggle up into
and have a nice safe sleep alright so
that's it for right now I want to thank
TK Coleman for being here for this
minimal episode you can find him at ek
Coleman dot-com what are you on social
media TK underscore Coleman on Twitter
right yeah there you go man and then on
Instagram you can check me out at
official TK Coleman and also check out
rev one on Instagram or go to feed out
Oryx lash Rev line for my website no
it's not advertising a moment
no it's not an ad no pay us anything no
I was if anything I was chuckling
because you've got three different
things and I know like if it was up to
you wouldn't be that way I think the
best spot you can find on TK Coleman
calm or follow them on your social media
platform of choice we'll put links
everything in the show notes well he
also is a director of education at fee
which is the foundation for a education
there we go and so we'll put a link to
that as well
real quick four right here right now
here's one thing that's going on in life
of the minimalist not a whole lot yeah
we are we are unfortunately cancelling
things we're still trying to figure out
we're gonna do with the podcast we
really appreciate your support so go
ahead and support us if you can check
out our resources page I mentioned that
minimalist rulebook it's on the the
resources page or the minimalists calm
slash resources a bunch of free
resources there nothing that you can pay
for on that page but free resources you
can check out including those sixteen
rules for living with less for our added
value this week Ryan
I was hoping you're gonna ask TK for a
Christmas loan recommendation not at all
because we are we are in the middle of
the end times or so we feel like yeah I
should have made your list for things
people can do to get through the
coronavirus what someone's a Johnny
Mathis yeah Marc Marc Maron has a new
special album perfect timing it is
called in times fun oh nice it just came
out and he recorded last year so he had
no idea but he does talk about some
apocalyptic stuff so I thought we would
instead of ending with a song this week
we're gonna end with about a minute and
twenty second bit that he has from his
new Netflix special and by the way Marc
Maron I've seen him live quite a few
times at the Comedy Store yeah this is
one of those rare occasions where it's
actually better filmed really and that
barely ever happens at stand-up totally
agree and since you're gonna be
self-quarantine eing anyway go ahead and
go home if you have Netflix check out
Marc Maron's new special in times fun
let's have some fun during these trying
times so we'll check out a little
snippet from that it's one of my
favorite jokes well it's one of the my
favorite ones that we can actually air
because there are some stuff there his
final joke is truly hilarious but we
couldn't put it on the podcast so tune
into that and if y'all leave here today
with just one message we hope it's this
love people and use things because the
opposite never works thanks for
listening y'all stay healthy oh thanks
and minimus